oh hi hi and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries where we choose you totally
worth it
today we're going to talk about at the
Meg the honest trailer for the Meg which
you hopefully already watched or not and
then check back here we're gonna go
through a thought process behind it and
if you stick around to the end you'll
get a little deleted scenes in the cut
jokes action you know the derp you know
the drill
that's Joestar I you know the Jo where's
Dan this week or not this week he was
here yesterday where's Dan no man he's
missed two of these yeah does he not
like us anymore I think there's
something weird going on no parents no
rules let's do it
we're talking to meg this is a big dumb
shark movie that we wished we're just a
little little better I think is the
little capsule review here like you got
this big shark you want to see the big
shark do certain big shark things and
maybe talk at the very least eat more
than one person at a time yeah yeah I
should just open its mouth and people
should just swept in like plankton yeah
the the whale from Pinocchio was scary
like it was teasing some kind of like
like kaiju on kaiju action when it ate
that big squid at the beginning but it
was like obscured by squid juice yes
squid ink yeah and then you're like okay
but it's that type of movie where that
kind of thing can happen but that kind
of thing never happens again no yeah
they really they really tease you with
giant squid and yeah I don't know this
this I understand on some of it cuz like
cheesy cheesy good is like such so bad
it's good it's such like a hard line
yeah and it's usually reserved for the
sharknados of the world who are maybe
expecting a little limited release but
this is talk about global the movie is
basically a tourist ad for China
yeah and come to beautiful China yes I
have wonderful beaches wonderful beaches
and obedient daughters who do their
father proud oceanography and they
protect the environment from the evils
of shark fishings so it was very much
obvious that this was a movie that was
playing to as wide a possible audience
namely the Middle Kingdom yes no
absolutely and you know even with like
sharknado like they know what they're
doing like that's bad bad but then
there's like deep blue sea which like
plays in the middle a little bit where
it's like is this bad or is it um I
think it's gotten worse and also better
with age because deep blue sea because
you look back on it and now there's this
whole sense of like wow what a what a
period of time that was yeah you had
your LL Cool J's and who else was in
that movie Thomas Jane Thomas chains
yeah in the world and your Sam Jackson's
before Thank You JT great pull Michael
wrap before is totally in that I don't
think we'll look back as fondly on this
crew I mean I love me some Statham yeah
we'll see that was the frustration is
like when you're like Jason Statham's
gonna fight the biggest shark ever yeah
I'm in yes cuz I love crank
I love crank too I even like the
mechanic series kinda because it just
stay from swinging around and kicking
people and need to keep making us well
and then you know you love his
furiousness
yes fastness yeah when I think Jason
state Statham now I think of really fun
b-movie Statham saving a baby on a plane
in a fast and furious movie and then
just like jealousy pumping against the
rock I want him to snap kick the shark
yes it's a it's a waste you had all the
ingredients there it's not that we hated
this movie I don't think either of us
hated it but it was like yeah yeah yeah
you got all the things together and you
just need to mix him up yeah yeah it
needed a little more stirring the
cornbread was a little lumpy
a little lumpy cornbread let's watch our
house trailer for lamech that's the
French they make the mega Jojo
more like megalith don't there are good
choices bad short movies and short
movies that are good because they're bad
but what if the short movie that should
be good bad tries to be good good with
just enough dumb fun to toe the line
between good bad and bad bad does that
make it good or does that make it a bag
from the country that brought you paper
gunpowder and tea comes one of judges
less important contributions to world
culture as this cha so produc the
interesting thing is that this movie
they did not expect it to make money in
the States this is one of those like I
don't like a sword and sandal movie or
like a sequel to a thing you wouldn't
expect to get it we're like well
internationally this will do really well
pack rim pack rim - exactly a perfect
example to you where it's like alright
well we'll look at the guy who made
three ninjas together we'll put a bunch
of Chinese famous people in it and then
like it'll make a hundred bazillion
dollars here and you know it'll do
whatever and then we rose to the
occasion USA was like nah now you know
what we're in some of this - we are in
yeah this is a three hundred plus
million dollar movie and it did about
the same domestic as it did there so you
know we have so much more in common than
our differences really the meg is about
togetherness yeah if nothing brings the
world together it's it's a fear of fish
yeah no absolutely yeah
Bing this is this movie is about
bringing together the star of I think
it's called Forbidden Kingdom which is a
pretty good movie and then Ruby Rose and
just letting them all play in the same
sandbox at the same ocean flashing
around together
yeah you come as this Chinese
co-production combines native actors
language and values the choice of a call
with the global appeal of stabbing a
judge if these co-productions are going
to continue okay I would very much I
will I will as an audience member go the
distance and just say you know what
everyone understands each other's line
which they just don't speak it so you'd
stop making people that don't speak the
other language natively just give these
very stilted phonetic performances right
like just be like oh yeah yeah I'll hop
aboard yeah like if someone just talks
to Jason Statham Chen Mandarin for a
while and then he's like I agreed I'm
fine I'm on board like okay he getting
he knows Chinese that's fine like just
let yeah it's a great cast it really
leaving being yeah the smaller child is
very cute yeah and the guy is cool Masi
oka well he's he speaks English yeah
American do but like but yeah just let
them they're they're great actors just
like let them act and it yeah let
everybody win it's like Esperanto how
about everyone speaks Esperanto yeah
it's a one language that we're that
everybody is gonna learn Esperanto so
there's no more language differences
that'll happen yeah I forgot God yeah
yeah do you think if we stick around
long enough we'll be speaking 70%
Chinese 30% English this is on screen
and off like in Joss Whedon's Firefly
yeah where there was lots of Chinese and
no Chinese people ah I see thanks just
good work but yeah just let me I'm fine
if I I will by Jason Statham speaking
any number of languages if you just let
those actors as we should wake Jason
Statham speak Chinese there should have
been a montage where he's like I think
I'm into her and then it's just him with
like what's a conscious yeah rosetta so
he can impress her I would have been
into that too yeah okay so okay keep
going
in the eye while it pulls a McTwist
me jason statham Jonah's tailor a man
made entirely done Hatton arrivals that
the hell make isn't a fight it's a small
talk when it discovers a trench is
actually a slightly deeper dredge all
right policies something we didn't have
time to really dig into Rainn Wilson who
at the beginning I mean it was really
hard to track because of the beginning
they're just doing deep blue sea words
yeah I'm the billionaire who's never
asked any questions about what I've been
spending billions of dollars I'd like
yeah what are you doing what how much
did this cost would yeah he's really
wanted to dig him you could have done a
side-by-side yeah he goes from being
that guy I actually I'm getting tripped
up because I have so many questions cuz
for one like he's in this for profit he
he goes from not caring at all about
money to being like we found a trench
underneath the Marianas Trench can you
imagine the value of this like what are
you gonna do with it yeah like drop Kate
came Arvest it yeah tours and then when
he finds the Meg again it's like you
know what that means profit like yeah
what's his game here he's full-on
underwear gnome right yeah fine giant
question profit yeah I don't know yeah I
don't I really don't know like if and it
just takes a line and you can make it as
stupid as you want because they set him
up at the meeting as like an idiotic
billionaire character and it seems like
like a philanthropist like this is just
his ocean research station because yeah
this is he made money I don't know
making like mobile games or something
okay and it's fine like I think it would
have been fine if he didn't care and was
just like what is this again I just got
told to invest in it and they're like
this is what we do and he's like sick
and then when they discover the Maggie's
like we're gonna make a reality show out
of this I want to take this fish to fire
fast yeah I like that [ __ ] we're gonna
turn this fish into a cryptocurrency
yeah and that wasn't and so people are
dying left and right because he's like
no rest till Meg coin yeah and
and then and then it's very satisfying
when he is eaten yeah instead he just
totally turns on a dime just because
they needed the newcomer to do the tour
of the station but then but he was so
aloof and didn't care where his money
was going in the beginning that the rest
of the movie his drive is to make a
profit off of this shark and I just
don't know what his plan yeah it's it's
weird yeah it's very weird yeah anyways
still get preferrence by rein in their
discovers a trench is actually a
slightly deeper dredge Jonas will have
to come out of retirement to save the
crew for a master sharp who lives there
all in the first 30 minutes but since
there's 82 minutes of moving left he's
getting crap scrap it while the story
awkwardly repeats itself with a hero
rescuing two different crews from two
different trapped sobs two different
women set up to be the love interest I
love it just think the whole thing that
gets him out of retirement is your
ex-wife
I mean groan right let go I gotta get
back your wife is down there you gotta
go get her
yeah he rescues her yeah she disappeared
from the movie yep she's she should have
been the again if this was the kind of
the movie that we more wanted it to be
they should have had this moment where
like they're about to reconcile and he's
like maybe they're like on the deck of a
boat and he's like maybe maybe did it
when this is all over and she's like
don't get too ahead of yourself by the
way I like the Hat he's like oh you and
then the Meg just like ha come on yeah
and then at the end having a romantic
dinner on the deck of the ship yeah
that's a midpoint and then it gets
personal because he ate the ex-wife that
he was about to get back with yeah this
time it's personal
exactly oh and then when he dives into
the Meg's mouth at the end she still
bears you know that's exactly right and
then the weird thing is that like he and
Li Bingbing they're like alright other
characters are all trying to get them to
hook up like yeah all like rude to the
point that it's weird yeah multiple
different people are like she's single
like she needs whatever and there's a
chemistry /language
area between the two of them their
relationship is mostly hand signals and
stuff like that waves and glances but
nothing ever happened
yeah it's really weird it for something
that they spend a lot of time
insinuating never happens and then it
gets even weirder cos like there's
there's really no chemistry between the
two which again I blame the they're
making her perform phonetically and
instead of actually just being able to
act but then at the end he like sits
down with the knees like with family now
or whatever little family it's like what
whoa I wanted her to be like oh no we're
not yeah dude I saw in the shower that I
kind of wanted to bang like can you get
away from my kid
hmm yeah I feel like the kid explained
to him how how relationships work and he
just took it on that you're very will
you go be with my dad be my mom dad is
like hell it works I've been too busy
drinking next to this shot Kolb's is
he's like you're very wise no but I'm
wondering if it's like that's why he's
like you're a very wise child yeah I'm
gonna get a beer also why is the beer
thing go away he should have been an
alcoholic the whole movie I think is
just the Heineken bought a scene and
they needed for Heinekens in the movie
and they decided to put all of them in
one area because he should have stabbed
the shark with a Heineken bottle man
like you should have been desperate and
just ha ha OH
Vin Diesel could have shown up in the
corona what I mean oh man yeah keep God
rest - helicopter attack sequences two
different mishaps with crazed
[Music]
shags wait what they kill the mag and
then there's a second mag then I just
watch the first movie and the sequel in
the same movie I honestly can't tell
that's a bargain or a ripoff
get all the mild carnage a pg-13 rating
will allow with plenty of just
off-camera violins that must have been
pretty horrible what they were looking
at come on you have five Meg books to
pull from and the first one starts off
with a Meg fighting a t-rex then ends
with Jonas ripping its horn from the
inside respect to Meg cannon because so
you see like it could have been worse
but it could have been better with we
read all the mag books and made all the
make it could have been better at the
bank yeah yeah I'll do that
alright I was just excited to discover
these were based on the books yes I had
no idea yeah jaws was based on a book
dragon mark based on a book I guess
there's a whole I mean I guess Michael
Crichton's the good version of it but
there's a whole genre of like b-movie
books yes it's like airport shark
Airport book shark yeah but I've been
enough airports and I feel like I would
have noticed yeah I don't think that
just said maybe with a shark eating a
t-rex yeah I would have also purchased
that yeah
that'll make this Southwest flight a
little better yeah I'll take the jerky
the Megan and the Rolo's large water but
I think in an earlier draft we had sort
of John getting weird the epic voice
mm-hmm
whoo John plays getting very excited to
discover that they are based on books
and I think you sort of took that
section and because I think we had like
kind of a weaker tag for this section
and you did a really good job of like
taking that and sort of twisting it
around to where it's like no he's
already a big fan of the books and it's
like come on guys and so much there's
gold in them pills he loves those
airport life I know
yeah absolutely just nothing but Meg and
Jack Reacher epic epic another good
crossover oh I'd watch that yeah I keep
going up here
I'll make that nice melody it's a huge
split but got a little two series where
its own good try something new
so the rest of your life isn't a vast
wasteland of misery and solitude how
awkward is also cause yes that was the
face of a man who is not listening to
this intense discussion with his ex-wife
I feel like he's about this to say
something like like I understand and
reciprocate those feelings oh I forgot I
forgot to get that from the store and
she's like wait what no that's not what
I said at all he's just a family my
ready for this the pilot subs keep going
sweet misery and solitude way too
serious I came here to celebrate with
you and now I'm mourning with you yeah
you guys don't worry about jumping the
shark punch the shark and punch it punch
the shark punch it now kick it aw come
on then diesel would have punched it in
real life not the first time we've used
that won't be the last either that's on
you Alan even squid the thin doctors
bake oh oh yes my spin doctors is this
possible ray will jump
Jurassic shark and that Aquaman poster
oh yeah we haven't got the title shut up
let's see if that's [ __ ] up Meg
we're in international waters which
means illegally could be the elevation
to you and get away with it retire this
joke that's not how international waters
work the flag your vessel flies is the
nation of laws you have to abide by and
since the station is flying the US flag
that would be subject to their
jurisdiction now that they did not fly a
flag and they were more than 12 nautical
miles offshore
that would mean you know what I'm
putting way too much thought into this
it's the Meg so yeah thank you - uh I
think we have combo it was a combo of
people yeah it was long and and Maura
who I believe was in the Navy in the
Navy so knows how international waters
work or rather don't and I mean what
movie doesn't say we're in international
waters everything mostly even landlocked
movies have that joke and it's baby
craisins just say crazy rich Asians had
that but the bachelor party on the on
the like oil barracks and it's like no
there's loss yeah there are was in the
ocean yeah there's laws on boats
regardless of the implication it's one
of the first things you learn in boat
law oh I'm sure there is boat law but
nevertheless let's watch some deleted
scenes or cut jokes oh you okay Jake you
story
Joss indistinct up and my dwarf is Jonas
Jonas bro recharge and Josh all a shard
Masi oka
fire hero academia
the man megalodons were thought to have
been extinct over two million years a
living fossil that living fossil late my
friend no observation I just really
loved that line this is what attacked us
their boss leaves a folder called bank
details all staff out of the desktop Wow
the shark should be the least of their
worries big cat I've got him we burned
them good yeah that's that's that I the
one thing I do want to see how this
movie now is just the run of outtakes of
him trying to say that living false
we'll just ate my friend that role
should have been Seth Rogen by the way
just us in my heart yeah but no that's a
tough one to deliver with a straight
face sure it was do just that living
fossil even the moments he does like
pull it off I dare I promise you cliff
Curtis is in the back just going that
guy should get more work by the way yeah
he's a he's a good unsung hero of film
and TV totally so what can I say that we
haven't just said about the Meg they'll
probably make more of them so they'll
have a chance to I believe they are it's
green lighter yeah more Meg's um I hope
they stick to the books make them maybe
they'll get a bigger budget they can
pull off some crazier stuff mm-hmm
abstain from comes back I think that it
should be personal the the meg should
eat his ex-wife and he shall kick it or
punch it
yeah at some point I agree or if he
doesn't come back that that same
character role should just be played by
a different actor every movie and that's
the gimmick okay it's like James Bond
yeah on fast-forward yeah exactly
who will be Jonas thank you always have
the straw hat no better keep going back
to Thailand like to the point we like
huh guy really likes Tyler same same tie
hey Mickey yeah
plays yeah and then you're all they
don't even advertise who's gonna play
Jonas Taylor
the head comes up and you're like it's
Roger Moore oh that would actually that
be disturbing he's dead yeah I know yeah
she like screwed up okay or this has all
been or this has all been a trick a ruse
so that you get really excited that a
he's still alive but he's Jonas Taylor
but we just go with like no you want
under the hat Stallone JD wants dallona
I know that yeah yeah can see and I'm
glad to do that
it's Tony Tony guy yeah cuz he wants
someone with the physicality that says I
could punch a shark mm-hmm and then does
yeah
and so Segal yes it's ago John Cena cuz
I by Segal who's like this guy just a
lot from very bloated like a few years
later yes still drinkin beer sauce a
little too hard been hiding at Thailand
and he's ready to a shark and then like
8 Meg's from now we're right and think
pieces about like I think the world is
ready for a female Jonas Taylor because
a female Meg then I guess I think the
second meg Meg is a surety for Megalodon
that's like calling you the hum for the
human yes that's in another world Meg's
are watching a movie about the hum
hunting a peg we could do the hum
starring a Segal and it's Statham versus
a giant Steven Seagal
yeah they release he's also living in
the Marianas Trench below the Marianas
Trench I think we've said a lot of
important thing yeah alright so join us
join these - hums next week the honest
trailer oh man it is an epic epic
showdown yeah a clash between men nay
the world
yeah really settled it a lot of things
permanently yep so look forward to that
and we look forward to our long weekend
which begins now but for this video the
past cuz we're pretty taping point is we
love you goodbye
you
[Music]